we got a brief overview of service
objects last season but it's time to
take a deeper dive
into services hiya caslin it's good to
see you
i was just getting ready to learn more
about services maybe you could help me
out
sure i remember how we covered how
services were used to abstract away pod
lifecycle events last season
right because pods are made to be
started stop terminated and created
but oftentimes applications need to have
a long-lived or permanent address to
reach
for interacting with services yes
so if you had a server back end for
storing images
it might not matter which pod serves the
data back to your front end
but the front end would always need to
know where to find your back-end to
request pictures
and since each pod gets its own ip
address that would be a lot to manage
you know storing an ip address whenever
a pod gets started or stopped
so services exist to store them for us
making our development much easier and
more scalable
but i remember we created a special type
of service last time called a load
balancer
what was that about well see
there's more than just one type of
service depending on what you're trying
to do
one may be more suited to your needs but
before that let's go into how to define
services if i had a set of pods that
each listen on tcp
port 9376 and carry a label app equals
my app
the yaml manifest file would look like
this
this specification creates a new service
object called my service
which targets tcp port 9376 on any pod
with the app equals my app label
this is taking traffic from port 9376
and routing it to the pod's default port
port 80 which greatly simplifies app
development
[Music]
wait a minute what iep address does the
service have
when i say it's getting traffic from
port 9376 that must mean the service
itself gets an ip address
right right kubernetes assigns this
service an ip address which is sometimes
called the cluster ip
and this brings us to the first type of
service the default cluster ip type
the cluster ip service type is only
reachable from other points within the
cluster
we actually used these before last
season to connect our front-end service
to the auth and back-end services
all of those were running in kubernetes
so they just needed a cluster ip to talk
to each other
so then the next type must be the load
balancer type that we also used in last
episode
well actually no see when you create a
load balancer type
service you can see that it actually has
an internal
cluster ip address the load balancer
service type
also uses what's called a node port
service underneath the hood
the documentation says a node port
service exposes a service on each node's
ip at a static point
this type of service also has a cluster
ip and to access it you reference the
node ip
node port address um please help me make
sense of why i
want to do this great question
you see the load balancer type actually
uses node ports under the hood
at some level pods are running on nodes
so the only way to access them is by
actually talking to the machine they're
on
the difference is that the load balancer
types are pre-configured to use a cloud
provider's load balancer for you
so if you're using gke on google cloud
you'll be using google cloud's load
balancer to distribute requests
from your service to your pod instances
but what happens if you're running
on-prem
and don't have a cloud-provided load
balancer or
what about when you want to roll your
own load balancer
oh in that case i need to access the
note port myself i guess
exactly so we have cluster ip services
for routing internal traffic
node ports for allowing external access
to a specific port
on a specific machine and load balancers
for using cloud provided load balancer
to route traffic between a service's
pods
that's pretty robust are there any other
types
well there are more advanced types of
services like external name services
or headless services and there's even a
higher level object called ingress
objects that are used to expose
multiple services but i think we can
save those for another day
many thanks to caslin again for
continuing to drop kubernetes knowledge
my way
i'm excited to go play with services
more and see what i can create for
myself
for more information about services
please check out the links in the
[Music]
description